Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is
Not Allowed To Do At The Foundation:
He should not replace the buckshot in Dr.
Clef's shotgun shells with any of the following:
birdseed, confetti, cake
sprinkles, sawdust, or glitter.
Being a loose-cannon, ex-GOC operative,
it goes without saying that Dr. Clef loves
his shotgun, and during containment breaches,
he’s the first to charge in with said
shotgun and face down his anomalous enemies.
However, as funny as Dr. Bright thinks
it may be, he really shouldn’t replace
Dr. Clef’s buckshot with any number
of amusing, harmless alternatives.
While seeing SCP-682 get a face full of
cake sprinkles certainly is something,
if Dr. Clef needs to spend another
week in traction as a result of it,
he’s going to have some
serious words for Dr. Bright.